what was it that you saw from jameis
winston coach that that made you
think this is a guy who can compete to
be a starting quarterback in my offense
he was a fantastic leader for our team
very supportive and loyal in that room
i think close with the quarterbacks um
and coming in
in in just his first year i i think he
endeared himself to
to his teammates uh he's he's a
tremendous worker
um and he's got a ton of talent
so you know he he he made a great
impression on us
oh and he did make a good impression uh
jameis winston making it clear that he
is back
with the new orleans saints for 2021 the
initial report
up to 12 million dollars on a one-year
deal for jameis winston
when the base value isn't part of the
leak
to shefty and he just runs with that up
to 12 million that tells you the base
value is nothing to brag about
and that there's a lot of incentives in
there so to get the 12 million
jameis has to be on the field
and taysom hill is getting at least 12
million now guaranteed the great irony
in this chris
because when taysom hill's ridiculous
phony
new contract came out sunday and it
caused people to think that he was
making 35 million a year on an extension
which was all baloney and bogus and bs
i said what is taysom hill getting out
of this what's he getting out of this
number one he's getting all of his money
it's all guaranteed number two
he's creating 7.75 million in cap space
so the saints can improve the team
around him and then they took that cap
space and they used it on
jameis winston who's gonna now try to
compete with
and and rason and tayson mill being the
the jack of all trades backup that he
was not the starter that he'd like to be
no i mean you're right but it's
everything we talked about yesterday it
just makes too much sense
it really does if you're jameis winston
why would you not want to go back there
you know as we've discussed a few times
you're with sean payton
it's a quarterback in front of you
that's unproven he gets in a lot of car
crash type hits when he carries the
football
i mean this is the spot for jameis
whitson so i'm just glad that
it got done for his sake because i think
we both looked at it and said no this is
the right move don't go somewhere
and take fool's gold just because ooh
it's a little extra money
or i got a you know a chance to to
really be the starter here
okay but you know let's not be on a
starter for a team that's not going to
show
or be able to show your abilities and
give you the support that way
so it's the perfect the absolute perfect
spot there
and you know we know look at this
offense just everything they do
sean payton it's it's a recipe for
success
week in week out it doesn't matter who's
in that quarterback the quarterbacks put
up good numbers and that's got to appeal
to any backup quarterback so i'm glad to
see jameis winston go there and good for
the saints too because he know they
wanted him back as well
i've never seen one player's
reputation affected more by one
play than jameis winston with the
overtime interception the overtime
interception
2019 we're watching the games i said
here we go here comes number 30.
here it comes remember that yeah there
it comes and there it came and if
he hadn't thrown that third if he hadn't
thrown that 30th interception in 2019
i think there's just a different vibe
about jameis winston this guy has a 5
000 yard passing season on his resume he
was the first overall pick in the draft
in his second season he was on an
mvp whisper track and they were winning
games
they they had a sunday night game that
was flexed into prime
time cowboys bucks they gave the cowboys
everything they could handle that was
the first year of dak
and zeke and the cowboys were really
good and they lost that game and the
bucks kind of fell apart after that
and that's been the problem the bigger
problem with winston this is what bruce
arians eventually articulated
december is when you step up not step
off right and too many times winston
steps off in december
but but i feel like that one
interception that one throw
has caused so many people to just assume
he's garbage he's not he's not that and
that doesn't mean he's gonna be the
starter
yeah he's he's got to win the job and
then he's got to prove it
but let's just not write this guy off
because he had a 30 intercept he's the
first 30 30 guy in league history
he's he he still has shown that he can
be good
and he's with a quarterback coach who
can make him great
yeah no doubt i mean what he did with
like what
like what you're saying he gave
everybody like the the headline of the
narrative
right like that's what he did oh 30 for
30. he's 30 30
30 30. oh yeah you know he's careless
with the football look at that last play
that that that last game he started as a
starter oh yeah that's right
interception pick six that's how they
lost it he let every
he let the narrative you know become
real that way
and listen it should be to a degree he
was careless with the football
and a lot of the times you used to talk
about it all the time he didn't know
when to abandon
you know ship and just throw the ball
away let the play die
take the sack punt the ball whatever you
know that's where he really struggled
but to your point i mean
the play making that he has shown
throughout his career is real
and there's been glimmers of really more
than glimmers like you're saying
really like some moments of a few weeks
in a row of consistent
really awesome quarterback play and
i know we talked about it last year when
he was a free agent and we tossed it
around because you and i were hearing
the same things there was
i think a lot of coaches who were
studying him coming
off the tampa bay buccaneers who were a
little blown away by what they saw i
don't think they realized how good he
was
all the good that you're talking about
you know whoa what a great throw
whoa the pocket's collapsing ooh he
moves better in the pocket than i
thought ooh look at him getting outside
the pocket man he's a better athlete
than i thought
whoa what a throw again you know i think
there was a lot of that and that's what
i think sean payton sees and
we're gonna see he's got his if he's the
real quarterback whisperer if he can get
jameis winston fix but
i am hopeful of it and i see the talent
like you do
i'm glad you reminded me of that dynamic
that always troubled me about
jameis winston and one of the very
limited things that i can bring to this
job from my
own athletic experience is
the effort consistently to try to do
more than my body would let me
do so i know it when i see it and that's
the one thing i can spot
an athlete who is who is not aware
of his or her own limitations and i
remember the first time i saw it jameis
winston florida state
oregon semifinal game when it was that
goofy thing where the
referee fell down and the ball slipped
out right
it's like you just have to know where
the limits of your god-given ability
are and you can't try to go beyond it
and that's been the fatal flaw for
jameis winston
far too often he tries to do more than
he's capable of doing and that is one
thing that i'm sure
the fact that we haven't talked about in
a year now it's not like he had a bunch
of opportunities
but that's going to be something sean
payton irons out you can't do
things that you just can't do that's job
number one you got to figure out what
you can do
and stay within those boundaries stay in
that backyard
and if he just does that if he just
masters that self-awareness on the field
right he could be a hell of a lot better
than he was in tampa bay definitely
like just learning to you know
call it quits on certain plays to
realize like john gruden used to say
like
hey the defense won this play there's
nothing wrong with that
they got professionals they got million
dollar players over there too they're
gonna win some of those plays
but when they win those plays don't you
know
compound it and make it a disaster or
that they totally
dominate you because now you you know
take a seven yard sack
or you try to force a ball because
nobody's open and you try to do
something that way
no you know that's where like rogers and
brady are great oh i'm about to get
sacked let me throw it away oh we're
it's still second and eight you know or
it's still second and ten we're not in a
bad spot
you know something like that oh man
everybody's covered there's nothing
there
okay okay let me give it one more pat to
see if somebody's else comes open no
they're not all right i'm gonna get the
ball out of my hand get it away
all right still second and ten we're
okay we can still manage the situation
and i think that's really where winston
you know failed
consistently not having that kind of
governor and and uh
i hope he can get it straight but he's
certainly at the best spot i think for
him to
to kind of take advantage of of his
opportunity and his talents
one last point there was a report last
night that the bears had interest in
jameis winston well if they really
wanted jameis winston as their starter
they could have gotten him because it's
a five and a half million dollar base
right for winston in new orleans and i i
i'm
this time of year i'm very skeptical
about reports that never can be proven
wrong how can you prove
wrong that the bears were interested
in winston if that's the report how can
you ever disprove that
well the bears aren't going to hold a
press conference and say that's false
and they're not going to bother right
now they're kind of busy with other crap
to stop and say that's baloney because
what happens is chris and this is the
challenge for everyone out there in this
business who's chasing news
you got to calm down no one's going to
fire you
because you don't have 50 scoops don't
don't
don't don't reach don't press don't
embellish
don't take something that's just a tiny
little nugget and blow it up into
something more
so you know your name gets on the crawl
at the bottom of the screen
and and i'm always that first day or two
of free agency
i'm always watching to see who gives
into that temptation
sure when they see all the it's all
flying fast and furious and
and i got to add something to this oh
the bears were interested in jameis
winston
okay thanks well done i know
jameis winston congratulations you're i
mean you're right you got to be careful
it's like we always talk about this time
in the year you don't want to really
listen to agents a whole lot
because you don't know what you know
they're they're selling you a bill how
many how many guys took less than they
could have gotten elsewhere
they all did right right it's a the bill
of goods everything like that
no doubt about it they're they're gonna
sell you you know on that player
or or the market that there is for him
and that was one when you see it and you
just
go you got to go you got to be able to
like
sift through the crap and the baloney
there and go like that doesn't make
sense i mean you know
nagi and pace they have a quarterback
stigma all over them are they really
going to bring in jameis winston and go
yeah this is the guy we're going to
stake our claim to
this is the guy that's a disaster for
both i mean just on
base level common sense nfl knowledge
that's where
you got to just a little go wait that
doesn't make sense for the bears
it doesn't make sense for jameis winston
can that really be
real and uh i think that's what you're
talking about here with this one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports